what's going on everybody welcome to
another Django tutorial video in this
video we're gonna be working on is the
actual deployment of a django
application to the cloud so the first
thing that we're gonna need is an actual
host for our servers I'm going to be
using Linode Linode is also a sponsor of
the series I've been with Linode for
almost a decade now and blue notice also
who hosts Python programming dotnet so
if you want to check out Linode you can
go to lynda.com slash synth X for a $20
starting referral credit sort of thing
so if you want to support me and check
out Linode and follow along on Linum you
can do that at lynda.com slash syntax
you can use other hosts if you want
there's tons of other hosters you know
google AWS digitalocean tons of hosts
there's also things like Heroku and
Python anywhere the issue I have with
them is it's really easy to get started
but then and it can also be cheap or
free to get started but then as you grow
it suddenly becomes far more expensive
to stay on those platforms so I would
suggest you don't start on them except
if you just simply cannot afford hosting
but for 20 dollars you'll last quite a
while it's gonna cost you about $5 a
month on linens so anyway at some point
you you're gonna need to learn how to
use VPS might as well do it now so we're
gonna use Linode also a cool thing with
Linode is we can do stack scripts so
I've actually shared a stack script
which is kind of like a shell script if
you don't if that is it's kind of like a
script that is going to do all the
things we're about to do and deploy like
a really Sam a basic sample django
application so you don't have to go
through all the steps every single time
it's good idea to learn how to do it at
least once but then from then it's like
super tedious you shouldn't do it every
time so super cool that we can just use
the stack scripts and I've shared it on
the community so you can launch your own
leonards
with that stack script so pretty cool
anyway what you're gonna do create an
account once you create an account go
ahead and there should be like a blue
create you'll choose create Linode
that's your no Linode is basically a VPS
once you're there we will choose for now
we're going to do everything our way by
you know the hard way by typing it in so
we're gonna choose older images and I
want a boon to 1804 LTS for long-term
support next pict region where do you
want the server to be I always choose
Dallas Texas nice center location in the
United States then I'm gonna pick nano
use the one gigabyte here $5.00 a month
pick a label I'm gonna call this Jango
video tutorial make a password and then
this is a quick American nuke it at the
end but seriously consider doing backups
later you can write a program to do
backups for you but until then enable
backups I have done it every time and I
have never regretted it I have needed
backups on many occasions and it's
always so nice to have them so until you
write your own just just enable them ok
I like create here and while that runs I
am going to also create one from a stack
script just to show you guys how
convenient they are so I'll choose
create from stack scripts now this is my
script so it's here in my stack scripts
but if you're watching this thing you
want to do it go to community stack
script search for syntax Gengo and then
you click on this one mm-hmm
now we'll come down here I'm not gonna
fill this in we're gonna use the
temporary Linode URL or yeah domain
basically it gives you keep this if you
want to change the project name have at
it just you're gonna have to change
other things as well well actually for
this X script you actually won't have to
do that but anyways if you want to
change it go for it production or test
this is basically for debug equals true
select your image we'll go with the same
one 18:04 select the region Dallas Texas
we'll go with nano de ghin label I'm
just going to call it stack scripts
example root password
there we go again
same thing on backups um I want to think
about doing it but for now hit create
okay once you've created
go to your Leonard's and then I'm gonna
go back to the Django video tutorial one
you don't have to spin up a stack script
like I did I just did it to show you
guys so for now I'm back in the one that
is not a stack script this is something
we're gonna write all ourselves so now
we want to connect to the server there's
a million ways you can do this on Mac
and Linux you can literally open a
terminal do ssh route at your IP address
so if I go to networking I can see right
here this is the one for me on Windows
you could use PowerShell in SSH via
PowerShell as long as Windows and
PowerShell is updated also we could just
click Launch console and connect this
way I'm not gonna do that because I want
to make the text really big and if I do
that this gets all glitchy on me so I'm
not gonna do that
I mean I'm super tempted to but I've
been bit too many times with that
console if i zoom it in so I'm not going
to do it instead I'm gonna use putty PU
TTY putty is also nice because you can
save profiles so you can save like a
domain name and like a user name that
way you don't have to keep track of them
if you're someone like me I've got like
I don't like 50 plus maybe even close to
a hundred servers so it's super
convenient to be able to save their
profiles anyway I've already got putty
downloaded so I'm just gonna type putty
and then to connect I just need the IP
here copy that paste that in there and
then you'll get this message the first
time you connect to any server it's just
a security sort of thing if this is the
first time you're connecting to the
server we expected it if this is a
server you connect to all the time like
you're connecting by a domain name for
example at a later date someone might
point that domain name somewhere else
that you don't intend and so this is
just a quick warning to you that that is
happening so this is a new server though
so we're confident we're comfy
we'll hit yes if you ever see that
message and it's not a new server
something is wrong but anyway we'll log
in now with the credentials that we set
boom we're in first thing I'm gonna do
is make this a little bigger so
everybody can see appearance will go
with maybe even bigger font I don't know
20 to apply beautiful okay first thing
we're gonna do pretty much every time
you ever spin up a Linux anything have
to get update apt is advanced package I
don't know what T stands for but it's
something like that it's your package
package manager kind of like PIP with
Python this is how you install packages
so the first thing you're always going
to do is an apt get update the next
thing we're gonna do is apt-get install
- why so we don't have to say yes this
is set like later like if you don't do
why it'll be like hey it's going to take
up such and such amount of space do you
want to do this you could say no I don't
know why you would so we're just going
to use the yes flag and we're gonna
install Python 3 pip we already have
python 3 on the system but we don't have
PIP so that's why we've got to do this
also a quick note we probably have
Python 3.6 not 3.7 just to save time I'm
not going to update 23.7 if you point if
you want to do that update 237 on your
own time I'm sure you could google it
for doing that but we're gonna skip that
it's going to take a bunch of time so
once we have pip let's make sure pip is
fully updated so python 3m pip install -
- upgrade pip cool I think from here on
- let me just say you can go to the
text-based version of this tutorial
scroll on down to where we start having
these commands boom you can just copy
and paste these in again also in the
future you can just run the Stax script
super quick and easy so just do that now
so once we've done that the next thing
we want to install is Django and that
Django app that we use so I'm just going
to take this copy right click to paste
usually depends on what you're doing so
a lot of times right click work
sometimes you've got to right-click and
paste and so on anyway so okay we've
installed Django and that app that we're
using so now we're gonna M cater which
is just make tur em cater any anytime
you lead with a slash so it's like
that's the root directory the very first
the base directory make Durbar www now
we're gonna see d VAR w w okay now what
we want to do is basically we're gonna
make that we're gonna start that project
so Django admin start project and we're
gonna call that my site okay so once
we've done that the next thing that we
want to do is we'll CD actually let's
just nano my site and then basically we
want to Nano
we're get in the setting so should be my
site yeah my site my site settings you
can also use tab to autocomplete so you
start typing some hit tab and it
autocompletes so the first thing we want
to do is debug shall be false next what
we want to do is come over to networking
and we're looking for this reverse DNS
this is for our temporary domain name so
I'm gonna copy that come over to allow
hosts paste that in cool again to keep
this short I'm not gonna talk about
domain names beyond here's how you do it
make a domain name you know register it
with a registrar on that registrar point
that domain name to the hosts name
servers so in this case would be Linode
name servers then on Linode you go to
like networking or dns or somewhere on
there then you'll point the domain name
to a specific Linode and then that
Linode will point based on the domain
name that you use cuz like you can have
like multiple web sites hosted off of
the same server in the cloud okay but
for the sake of brevity this is the way
we're gonna do it so allow it host
that's fine later we're gonna have to
add it a couple more things but for now
control X yes hit enter cool alright so
also uh Nano is an editor so it's just a
basic editor lots of people like vim as
well but I prefer Nano so you Nano and
then the thing that you want to edit
okay so the next thing that we're gonna
do is start a new app so we're going to
Python 3 my site slash managed up PI
start app and then we're gonna call this
it works cool now we're gonna do is I
think I'm gonna start copying and
pasting again so let me come over here I
don't want to have to like write all
this stuff out this is just for like a
really quick example anyway so let me
scroll down to where we are it works ok
so first let's CD into mice
site and then we're going to nano my
site URLs depay because we have to point
that to our new app so I'm going to take
this copy if you hold ctrl + K and Nano
it deletes lines at a time so delete it
all the lines paste in the code control
X yes enter done now we're going to come
over to the URLs for the app and again
that's blank so we're just gonna copy
and paste that in X yes or ctrl X yes
you're writing what happened
hold on my site
LS Oh
it almost looks like we did we didn't
get I wonder if I can't do this sort of
pathing I think this is what screwed us
up let me go back one yeah ooh that's
gross
so let me RM - our remove recursively it
works hopefully I didn't screw us up any
further anyway yes
CD my site LS for listed out managed at
PI let's create that one more time
Python 3 managed up hi
start app it underscore works okay
anyway
let's try that one more time nano it
works URLs now PI and then copy paste
that stuff in yes by the way for sure by
now our stack script is done just take
note
anyway now let's do the views so Nana
okay so take this paste those in control
X yes save okay cool
all right that's all the Django stuff
okay so now you basically we've got our
server in the cloud
we've got Django set up now we need to
set up our web server and then for a web
server to talk to Django we need an
intermediary and that's where WSGI comes
in WSG is stands for web server gateway
interface and it just kind of
communicates between your your web
server software and whatever framework
we are using so to get that that's these
commands here so Afghan install again
yes Apache 2 which is our web server and
then WSGI yes someone will ask why not
ngx or nginx fix why not nginx because
we had to pick one okay so we picked one
Apache done question answered okay so
then what we're going to do is fill in
the virtual host information so again
I'm just
be doing some copy and paste in here my
side comp and then yeah I'm just gonna
copy and paste that virtual host stuff
and this is a good example of basically
at this point your web server can
actually serve many websites so our
server here runs a web server and then
that web server comes to this virtual
host file and then looks at the hostname
and if it matches the hostname does
things based on that match so so first
we have to fill in this hostname so
again that hostname if we go here
networking it's this this is our
hostname
so it basically would be your domain
name if you pointed a domain name here
but for now we're just gonna use that so
delete hostname paste that in also for
some reason my copy and paste puts this
on a new line make sure that doesn't
happen
yeah that's gonna hit a nasty error so
I'm actually going to delete here so
that's up in line with this variable
here okay so hopefully it doesn't screw
us up anyway control X yes enter okay so
that's your my site kampf and I we are
probably done we might have to do one
more thing let me check let's first do a
2 n site my site and then it just says
hey to activate the new configuration
you can run this I believe you can also
just run the service Apache to you
reload but we'll do this ok now let's go
and visit this URL hopefully it works ok
for now we're getting the default Apache
page I'm trying to think of all the
reasons why that would be but one is
probably our default settings are not
quite what we were hoping so let me go
let's nano and in fact we'll run these
two commands
first we want to delete that default
config so we're gonna just RM for remove
and we're going to remove this is 0 0 0
- default conf
because we want that to agree so then
we're gonna Nino that default
configuration file and then we're gonna
copy and paste in some really basic
information here but basically this way
this doesn't have any preference on
hostname save yes
now let's reload Apache 2 again ok great
so now it works so before we at probably
had a whole bunch of other setting
information in there that we didn't need
for the default settings because we
already set those but somewhere in there
it was probably specifying a hostname
that we didn't care for so everything
works now and we've served a basic
Django app now think about all the
things that we just did to get to this
point ok we put in a decent amount of
work now let's look at our snack script
website so head over to your Linode or
if you did it anyway
let me pull up my stack script okay so
here stack scripts stacks you know what
I'm trying to say ok so this is our
domain so to speak copy that come over
here paste that one ok and that one's
already done so that one really it just
takes as long as it takes to like do
like the apt-get stuff and the updates
and stuff like that it you know it's
like 2 to 3 minutes or something so you
can just spin that up go get a drink of
water and you're probably all set
so speaking of drinking so ok so up to
that point that's a really basic django
app but probably what you really want to
do is deploy the project that you've
been working on all this time so how do
we do that well first we have to get the
project files on our server there's a
bunch of ways one you could have started
working on the server but two you
probably worked locally and then you
want to put it up on the server there's
a million ways to do this probably the
biggest one would be like SCP if you're
on Mac or Linux you just have an SCP
command in your terminal on Windows you
also have SCP in
Rochelle and you just SCP from a
location to a location and there's lots
of tutorials on that also like on
Windows there's win SCP which is like a
GUI version of SCP also you can do SFTP
to like move files to a server securely
using something like FileZilla also
pretty popular anyway there's a tons of
wait there's so many ways to copy those
files to the server what I'm gonna do is
since I've already hosted the website
we're just gonna pull it from because
I've hosted it okay so if we go to the
back to the text measure of the tutorial
blah blah blah blah blah here yeah so
we're just gonna W get that part eleven
Django so I'm just going to copy that so
now what we're gonna do CD back a
directory so dot dot is backwards and
now we're gonna RM - our my site because
we don't actually want that
that's a stupid little app so so we got
rid of all that now we're gonna do is W
get which grabs like content offline and
we're gonna grab that Django part 11 zip
file boom done now we're gonna apt-get
install unzip we could also use I think
like tar or something like that but tar
is like really just a pain in the butt
to use unzip is really simple
unzip Django 11 like anytime I want to
use tar I have to like google the
commands and it's annoying anyway so
we've unzipped it now we could do LS
again there it is my site is there okay
now we have to do all the things we had
to do before basically so first we need
to edit the settings so Nano my sites my
site settings dot pi come down into here
and we're gonna set debug so that's a
false then what we want to do is grab
this again set that as our host okay
great
the other thing I want to point out
before I forget Django deployments
go to the Asheville jingo docks cool and
click on deployment checklist definitely
go through this this has a lot more
things so again I can't cover all the
security things like for example we're
using root user probably in practice you
would make your own pseudo or users and
then probably disable the root user
account also you're probably not gonna
log in with passwords you're gonna use
an SSH key there are so many like little
things when it comes to like using web
servers again that I can't cover all in
one video it would have to be like an
entire tutorial series ok so anyway hmm
here's another thing you should just
check out go to the deployment checklist
one of the things probably the first
things for a secret key probably save
your secret key in some sort of file
somewhere outside of your Django project
so in this case they're hiding it in in
you know basically the leading /root
door et Cie and then the secret key put
it somewhere outside of the project
files that way for example if you have a
permission issue or later like if you
decide to share this with people on
github you don't share your secret key
by mistake on github you can literally
search for strings and stuff and you can
write a program that would just go
through everything looking for people's
secret keys you probably want it you
don't want that to be you so anyway go
through the checklist there's lots of
stuff here anyway back to what we were
doing ok so we sent aloud hosts great I
think that should be like everything we
have to do at this point before we could
test it we're is gonna be more things
that we have to do for sure but anyways
now let's service Apache to reload and
let us already forget which one was it
9:14 is the one we want to check so I'm
gonna close the other one so I don't
screw up refresh ok those are tutorials
aren't they beautiful so what's going on
ok the issue is our static is not
loading so in production we have to
handle static
a little differently so I'm gonna just
come back to our tutorial here and we
need to edit that settings not pi again
we're gonna scroll down to the very
bottom just hold that down arrow okay
underneath static URL we want to add
these three new things cool now from
here what we want to do is like our
static files are in many locations if
you remember each app has its own static
files what we need in production is them
actually to all be in one location so
Jango has a little script for us that's
already doing this so control X Y s to
save enter what we want to run is let's
CD into my site yeah Python 3 managed PI
and it should be collect static great so
all our files have been moved to the
same location on our actual web server
bar ww-why site static now if we come
back to our website refresh boom
everything's working again so now we
could do things like click on data
analysis hopefully and then click on
like panda is okay everything is working
it looks like our style styles are here
blah blah blah blah alright now there's
a couple of things we need to talk about
yeah that the two things we need to talk
about are one as a few people up the
deployment tutorial is well it's not yet
over sorry we got to talk about
ownership so actually let's do the
ownership thing first okay so so if we
attempt to login oh login doesn't course
crush okay we're not going to do that
first we're gonna do the URLs first so
what happened to our URLs darn it okay
so if wait yeah so if we nano main URLs
dot I our issue is these darn slashes so
at least in flats like if you hat like
in a path if you have a slash in a path
it will correspond to things that have
slashes or don't have so you
someone if you have that path and
register and someone does register but
not a slash it will still direct them to
that that location if you don't have the
slash but someone adds the slash it's
gonna fail so I always like to add to
the trailing slash but in this case it's
causing trouble so what I'm just gonna
do for now short quick solution is
delete all the trailing slashes ctrl X
yes great now refresh this page maybe we
have to redo - maybe I have to reload
Apache let's try again ok now it works
so now we could actually like login and
register and all that so let's try let's
try sent X what happens okay we hit a
server error 500 so this is super
useless to us at the moment later you'd
probably want to have some sort of error
handling that again
can either email you or save to a file
like you're using logging and stuff like
that but for now we just get this ugly
error luckily I already know what the
problem is the problem is we can't act
we can only we can read from the
database but we don't actually even have
permissions fully to do that because
we're not able to actually confirm this
thing anyway what we need to do is give
the user that's attempting to read that
database permission to do so
so back over here we can see the two
commands basically what we want to do is
CD back a directory and then we want to
do channel owned or CH owned for is it I
think it's w w data let me make sure
yeah so that's the username for your
Apache user basically so we want to give
that user access I want to make sure I
get this right but it should just be
yeah the my site directory and then we
want to give them access to the SQLite
database so my site and then we'll give
them WWD data my site slash I think yeah
DB sqlite3
cool and then let me just reload Apache
cool now we'll just go back to login
let's try to login one more time cool
we've logged in awesome ok so the last
thing what was the other thing oh we
actually had to do it in order we had to
do the URLs in the ownership so actually
I think we're done I think we're done
I'm trying to think if I've missed
anything I don't think so
so that was deployment in Django ok so
again if you guys want to use Linode to
kind of support the channel but also get
$20 in credit that's just lynda.com
slash sin tax if you guys got questions
comments concerns suggestions whatever
feel free to leave them below if I
forgot something let me know
also if you've got requests for future
coverage let me know that as well I've
seen a lot of requests for the Django
rest API stuff the only thing it just
doesn't quite fit this example but maybe
like a delayed later project like it
looks like the main use case there would
be like single page app unless you're
like making some other sort of restful
api type thing but anyway so I might
cover that but it doesn't really fit
this example so unless I'm totally done
with the Python program yet stuff let me
know what you guys would like to see in
the future otherwise that's it for now
thanks for the support the subscriptions
the channel membership the donations all
that stuff and I will see you guys in
another video